[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى الحلقه الجديده هذه
من مستقبل الطاقه وهذه ملفاتنا
اوروبا تبحث عن تعريف جديد لامن الطاقه
بعد صدمه الحرب الاوكرانيه
تقلص طموحاتها المناخيه وتمتدح اوبك
[موسيقى]
لطالما تغنى صناع السياسه الغربيه
بالمكاسب الجيو السياسيه التي سيجنونها
جراء عمليه التحول نحو الطاقات الخضراء
حيث كانوا مقتنعين بان التحول السريع الى
مصادر الطاقه النظيفه لن يساهم في مكافحه
تغير المناخي فحسب بل سيتجاوز ذلك ليضع
حدا للصراعات الجيويه السياسيه التي تعتري
منظومه الطاقه التقليديه الا ان تلك
الامال لم تكن الا ضربا من الخيال فتحول
الطاقه سيكون على الاغلب عمليه فوضويه قد
تنهي الصراعات القديمه الا انها حتما
ستخلق غيرها في خريف عام 2021 دخلت اوروبا
في اوتون ازمه طاقه دفعت اكثر المتحمسين
تفاؤلا لتحول الطاقه للاعتراف بانه لن
يكون تحولا سلسا عقبها ذلك اندلاع الحرب
في اوكرانيا في فبراير من عام 2022
لتكشف الحرب عما خفي من المخاطر التي
انتجتها عمليه غير منسقه لتطوير مصادر
طاقه جديده وللتخلص من منظومه الطاقه
التقليديه القائمه انكشاف عيوب عمليه
التحول غير المنسقه تلك وازمه الطاقه التي
نتجت عنها او اقله تفاقمت بسببها جاء
ليعيد ترسيخ امن الطاقه كاولويه على
اجندات صناع القرار ولكن بمفهوم جديد ففي
الماضي كان امن الطاقه يعرف على انه توفير
كميات كافيه من امدادات الطاقه باسعار
معقوله الا ان هذا التعريف البسيط بات غير
كاف ليعكس واقعنا الحالي ومخاطره
المتشابكه والمعقده وفي هذا الاطار يرى
الباحثان الاكاديميان جيسون
في مقال اخير لهما بان العالم قد دخل
بالفعل في زمن انعدام امن الطاقه مستعرضين
ما يرونه بانها مصادر الاضطراب الرئيسيه
الثلاث التي تقود انعدام هذا الامن اولا
عوده المنافسه ما بين القوى العظمى ضمن
منظومه دوليه متعدده الاقطاب فالبيئه
الجيو السياسيه تؤثر في وتيره ونطاق
التحول وفي هذا الاطار من المرتقب ان
المنافسه الاستراتيجيه ما بين الولايات
المتحده والصين ستلعب دورا مهما مستقبلا
في زعزعه امن الطاقه عالميا في حين ان
مصدر الاضطراب الثاني هو توجه العديد من
الدول نحو تنويع وتوطين سلاسل امداداتها
وهو امر سينعكس اضطرابا على منظومه اسواق
الطاقه العالميه اما مصدر الاضطراب الثالث
فهو ذيول التغير المناخي فهو مصدر خطر
يهدد البنيه التحتيه للطاقات التقليديه
والجديده كليهما من خلال الاعاصير
والفيضانات
والعواصف وفي ضوء مصادر الاضطراب الثلاث
تلك يقترح الباحثان بورد اوفن اربعه مبادئ
اساسيه ستساعد صناع السياسات على اعاده
تعريف مفهوم امن الطاقه وتطوير ادوات
جديده لتحقيقه وهي التنويع وقدره التحمل
والتكامل والشفافيه فعمليه تحول الطاقه
ستعزز بشكل تلقائي من امن الطاقه عبر
تنويع مصادر الطاقه وتنويعي موردها في حين
ان تعزيز قدره التحمل والمرونه روزيليانس
لدى منظومه الطاقه لتجاوز الصدمات سيكون
امرا جوهريا مستقبلا اما التكامل فسيكون
من المهم الحفاظ عليه من خلال اسواق طاقه
مترابطه التي يجب ان تقاوم الانجرار نحو
السياسات الحمائيه واخيرا فان الشفافيه
التي بات يعهدها العالم في اسواق النفط
والغاز يجب ان تمتد لتشمل اسواق الطاقه
الجديده ومدخلاتها ومعادنها حيث يجب على
الدول الافصاح عن انتاجها واستهلاكها
ومخزوناتها في هذا الاطار لوضع رقابه اقوى
لمنع التلاعب والمضاربه عليها مستقبلا
يحذر الباحثان بوردوفون بان على صناع
السياسات ان يدركوا جيدا المخاطر المستجده
التي اصبحت اليوم تهدد امن الطاقه كما
يطالبونهم بتحديث ادواتهم المستخدمه في
مكافحه تلك المخاطر وينبه الباحثان بان
هذا المسعى لا يعد الهاءا عن مكافحه
التغير المناخي بل على العكس تماما يرونه
بانه امر يصب في صلب هذه الجهود حيث
يخلصان الى انه من دون تحقيق امن الطاقه
فان ازمات الطاقه المحتمله مستقبلا قد
تدفع بقطار صافي صفر انبعاثات للخروج عن
مساره
[موسيقى]
من التفكير الاوروبي في شان التوازن بين
طموحات التحول الى الطاقه النظيفه واهداف
امن الطاقه طرحت هذا السؤال على الدكتور
عايشه السريحي الزميل المشارك في معهد
الشرق الاوسط في جامعه سنغافوره الوطنيه
لنستمع الى مقاله في هذا الحوار مع مستقبل
الطاقه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وضعت ملف
امن الطاقه في الواجهه امام باقي الملفات
من ضمنها ملف التغير المناخي وذلك بسبب
ان من ضمن تداعيات الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه هو احداث فجوه في امن الطاقه
وايضا التسبب في احداث ارتفاع كبير او
قياسي في اسعار الغاز واسعار الطاقه بشكل
عام وذلك بسبب محاوله بعض الدول وخصوصا
الدول الاوروبيه
بالضغط على روسيا من اجل
ايقاف الحرب في اوكرانيا وهذه المحاولات
تمثلت في على سبيل المثال فرض عقوبات على
روسيا او تقليل الاعتماد على واردات النفط
والغاز الروسي
فاوروبا تعتمد على سبيل المثال بحوالي 35%
على الواردات الروسيه في تلبيه
طلب على النفط في في اوروبا وايضا تعتمد
بحوالي 40% على واردات روسيا لتربيه الطلب
على الغاز في الدول الاوروبيه
من ضمن العقوبات او محاولات الضغط على
روسيا قامت الدول او المفوضيه الاوروبيه
باصدار
خارطه الطريق
تتمثل في خفض
الاعتماد التدريجي على واردات الطاقه
الروسيه وهذا احدث فجوه في امدادات الطاقه
في الدول الاوروبيه وفي دول العالم في في
سوق الطاقه بشكل عام وايضا تمثل ايضا في
ارتفاع قياسي في اسعار الطاقه حيث ارتفعت
اسعار طاقه بحوالي 20 مره مقارنه باسعار
الطاقه في عام في نفس الوقت في عام 20 20
فهذا كشف فعلا النقاب عن عدم التوازن بين
اهداف الطاقه المتجدده
وامن الطاقه وذلك بان الازمه كشفت ان
مصادر الطاقه المتجدده ليست على قدر
الاستعداد في مواجهه مثل هذا التحدي
المفاجئ في امن الطاقه لعله من المفيد لنا
وللمشاهدين دكتور عائشه لو مررنا مره اخرى
بالاحداث والعوامل التي ادت الى تلك
القفزات القياسيه في اسعار الغاز والطاقه
عموما في اوروبا العام الماضي الازمه حدثت
مباشره ما بعد التعافي الاقتصادي من ازمه
كوفيد
ومحاوله الدول للسيطره على انتشار الفيروس
تمثلت في
تقليل مفاجئ في الطلب على
مصادر الطاقه منها النفط ومنها الغاز وهذا
ايضا خلال ازمه كما نعلم في عام 2020
اسعار الطاقه
انخفضت بشكل حاد جدا وهذا ادى الى عدم
قدره المستثمرين في
توفير راس المال اللازم في الاستثمار في
مجالات في مصادر الطاقه جديده او في عمليه
صيانه الطاقه فهذا احدث خلل او احدث نقص
في اصدار في امدادات الطاقه وايضا
عمليه التعافي الاقتصادي من ازمه كوفيد
اعاده الطلب على
مصادر الطاقه بشكل كبير وهذا ايضا ادى الى
الارتفاع التدريجي في
اسعار الطاقه والازمه الروسيه الاوكرانيه
في الحقيقه ادت الى تخفاقم في ارتفاع
اسعار الطاقه
الاتحاد الاوروبي لطالما كان دكتور عائشه
في طليعه الدول العالم المستثمره في
الطاقات المتجدده منذ سنوات طويله قبل
الازمه الاخيره لماذا اذا لم تستطع قدرات
الاتحاد الاوروبي من الطاقات المتجدده ان
تملا الفجوه في امدادات الطاقه الناتجه عن
الحرب في اوكرانيا والتعافي السريع من
جائحه
رغم ان مثل ما ذكرت ان الدول الاوروبيه في
طليعه الدول في في تحفيز الاستثمار في
مجالات الطاقه المتجدده
واحتضانها لما يسمى او الصفقه الخضراء الا
ان الازمه كشفت انه فجوه كبيره بيننا
طموحات هذه الدول وبين واقع الاستثمار في
مجالات الطاقه المتجدده
الاستثمارات الحاليه والمشاريع الحاليه في
مجال الطاقه المتجدده
ليست كافيه لتلبيه الطلب المفاجئ على
الطاقه واستبدال الوقود الاحفوري بمجالات
بمصادر الطاقه المتجدده فبشكل عام اليوم
مصادر الطاقه المتجدده
تشكل حوالي
29% فقط من
القدره الانتاجيه الاجماليه للكهرباء في
العالم وهذه
وهذه
الغالب غالبيه الطاقه هي اصلا تاتي من
مصادر الطاقه الكهرومائيه
الشمس والرياح تغطي فقط 10% من قدره
الانتاجيه العالميه
للكهرباء
لتلبيه امن الطاقه وفي ذات الوقت ايضا
تامين سياسات
او التامين المناخ
دول العالم بحاجه الى رفع انتاجيه
مصادر الطاقه المتجدده الى 60% بحلول عام
2030 والى حوالي 90% بحلول عام
فهنالك فجوه كبيره جدا في الاستثمارات
الاستثمارات الحاليه في مجال الطاقه
المتجدده هي اقل من واحد تريليون دولار
للوصول الى الحياه الصفري واللي ايضا
التامين
مصادر الطاقه في المستقبل
فهذه الاستثمارات يجب ان تزداد بحوالي
ثلاث مرات ضعف من الاستثمارات اليوم اي
بنحو اثنين فاصل واحد تريليون ما بين 20
22 الى 25
والى الضعف بحلول عام
2030 طبعا نتحدث هنا بعشرين ثلاثين اكثر
من اربعه ترليون دولار سنويا من
الاستثمارات المستهدمه المستهدفه في
الطاقات المتجدده وهذا يقارن مع تريليون
دولار سنويا حاليا فجوه استثماريه ضخمه
بالفعل دكتور عائشه ما هي تبعات ازمه
الطاقه في 20 22
الى اضافه الى التدابير الطارئه التي
اتخذت في ضوء هذه الازمه على عمليه التحول
نحو الطاقات النظيفه على المدى القصير
على المدى البعيد هل سيستنتج صناع
السياسات بان الحل
يكمن في تسريع وتيره التحول ام سيستنتجون
بانهم ما زالوا غير جاهزين لهذا التحول
وانهم سيحتاجون للمزيد من الغاز والوقود
الاحفوري بشكل عام على المدل القصير الى
المتوسط
الازمه
الطاقه المتجدده ليست على قدر الاستعداد
لمواجهه
الطلب المفاجئ
وتلبيه الفجوه في امن الطاقه
على المدى القصير ومثل ما شاهدنا ان
ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه وايضا
التضخم الذي حصل نتيجه الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه هذا ادى الى دفع كثير من الدول
من الدول الاوروبيه ودول اخرى في اسيا
وايضا امريكا للبحث عن مصادر بديله لتلبيه
امن الطاقه وايضا
خفض اسعار الطاقه
دول اوروبيه مثلا ودول اسيا وامريكا
قامت باستخدام الفحم من اجل تلبيه الطلب
على الطاقه عن مستوى المحلي وهذا يتناقض
مع سياسات هذه الدول المحليه في مجال
التغير المناخي كيف اثرت ازمه الطاقه
الاخيره على الجدل القائم دكتور عائشه حول
كيفيه تحقيق التوازن ما بين السياسات
المناخيه والنمو الاقتصادي في السابق كان
لدى
المؤيدين لساسات تغير المناخي تحفظ حول ان
النمو الاقتصادي ياتي على حساب التغير
المناخي ولكن الاسماء الحاليه او الازمه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه كشفت ان ايضا سياسات
التغير المناخي اذا لم يتم تصميمها بشكل
سليم سوف سوف ايضا تؤثر على النمو
الاقتصادي بطريقه عكسيه
فتصميم سياسات التغير المناخي يجب ان ياخذ
في الاحسبان بعض الحقائق وان ياخذ ايضا في
الحسبان
التبعات السياسات
المناخ وما قد ينتج عنه من تاثير عكسي على
النمو الاقتصادي او احداث اي فجوه في مجال
المساواه المجتمعيه
فعلى سبيل المثال الدول
الاكثر تضررا بالتغير المناخي وهي الدول
الناميه هذه الدول هي الاقل حظا من
توفر السياسات التي تدعم
التقليل من اضرار التغير المناخي وبما في
ذلك هي الاقل حظا من استثمارات الطاقه
المتجدده فبعض الدراسات تشير على ان
الاستثمارات في مجال الطاقه المتجدده يجب
ان تزداد بحوالي اربعه بليون في الدول
الناميه من اجل
تقليل اضرار التغير المناخي في هذه الدول
اذا ما هي الدروس والعبر التي استقاها
العالم من ازمه الطاقه خلال العام الماضي
فيما يخص السياسات الاكفى بهدف موازنه امن
الطاقه بكلف معقوله وما بين امن المناخ
الحكومات لها دور كبير في تحديد سياسات
تغير المناخ وفي ايضا اداره الازمان
والتدخل في سوق الطاقه وهذا يشير على ان
الحكومات لها دور كبير في انشاء تكافؤ بين
سياسات امن الطاقه النمو الاقتصادي وايضا
الانتقال الطاقي فهذه الاسماء تشير انه
لابد
من اجل احداث هذا التوازن بين الانتقال
الطاقي امن الطاقه والنمو الاقتصادي انه
لا بد من تطوير واعتماد عده مصادر للطاقه
بدلا من اعتماد على مصدر واحد من اجل
تامين مصادر الطاقه وتجنب التذبذبات
الاسعار في المستقبل وايضا كشفت الازمه
الى ان مصادر الطاقه المتجدده قد تلعب دور
جدا مهم في تامين مصادر الطاقه على
المستوى المحلي
وذلك
ولذلك السبب فان هذه الازمه تشير على
اهميه الاستثمار بشكل مبكر واعتماد
السياسات بشكل مبكر في الاستثمار في
مجالات الطاقه المتجدده من اجل احداث
التوازن المطلوب بين النمو الاقتصادي
الامن الطاقي
وايضا سياسات التغير المناخي
نتوقف الان المشاهدين مع فاصل القصير
نتابع بعده بقيه مستقبل الطاقه ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى مستقبل الطاقه نفت
ارامكو ما تناولته بعض الوكالات الاعلاميه
عن توجه الشركه لايقاف مؤقت لخططها
للهيدروجين الازرق واكدت ارامكو على هدف
الشركه المعلن في يونيو من العام الماضي
والمتمثل بانتاج ما يصل الى 11 مليون طن
من الامونيا الزرقاء المنتجه من نحو
مليونيتون من الهيدروجين الازرق بحلول عام
2030 مع الاشاره هنا الى ان القدره
العالميه لانتاج الهيدروجين الازرق كما
بنهايه العام الماضي تبلغ اقل من مليون طن
فقط 900 الف طن تحديدا والهيدروجين الازرق
هو ذاك المنتج من الغاز الطبيعي بالاضافه
الى استخدام تقنيات احتجاز الكربون وتخزين
تاتي تلك التقارير الاعلاميه المغلوطه بعد
تصريحات ادلى بها الرئيس التنفيذي لارامكو
امين الناصر في اتصال مع المحللين اشار
فيها الى الصعوبه الحاليه في ايجاد عملاء
في اوروبا واسيا مستعدين لتوقيع عقود شراء
طويله الاجل للهيدروجين الازرق بسبب سعره
المرتفع الذي يساوي نحو 250 دولار لبرميل
النفط المكافئ حاليا واشار الناصر الى ان
ارامكو رجحت كفت انتاج الهيدروجين الازرق
وليس الغاز المسال لكونه وقودا اكثر نظافه
من حيث بصمته الكربونيه تجدر الاشاره الى
ان ارامكو اعلنت عن خططها لتطوير حقل
الجافوره العملاق لانتاج الغاز الحامض
بقيمه استثمارات قد تصل الى 110 مليارات
دولار حيث يحتوي الحقل على احتياطات تقارب
200 ترليون قدم مكعبه وتهدف ارامكو بدء
الانتاج من هذا
وعشرين لتصل كميه غاز البيع الى نحو
مليارين قدم مكعبه يوميا عام 2030 وتخطط
السعوديه لاستخدام معظم انتاج الجافوره في
الاستهلاك المحلي وتصدير الفائض كهيدروجين
ازرق وقد ارسلت ارامكو بالفعل ثلاث شحنات
تجريبيه من الامونيا الزرقاء حتى الان الى
عملائها في كل من اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]
في عز جائحه كورونا عام 2020 ومع انهيار
اسعار النفط صدمت صناعه النفط والغاز
باعلان شركه بي بي عن خطتها الاستراتيجيه
الراديكاليه للتحول نحو الطاقه النظيفه
والتي شملت مستهدفاتها خفضا كبيرا في
انتاجها من النفط والغاز وزيادته طبعا من
الطاقات الخضراء لكن بعد اقل من ثلاث
سنوات فقط وتحديدا في فبراير الماضي عادت
بيبي لتقلص مستهدفاتها المناخيه الطموحه
تلك بالتزامن مع تحقيقها ارباح تاريخيه
على خلفيه الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
ويبدو ان هذا التحول في المستهدفات طاله
ايضا اراء الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه التي
يبدو بانها اصبحت اكثر واقعيه في جلسه
حواريه له مع الملياردير ديفيد روبنس تايم
في النادي الاقتصادي في واشنطن هذا
الاسبوع اكد بيرناد لوني ان وقف انتاج
النف بين ليله وضحاها كما يطالب البعض امر
غير عملي فانه اذا انخفض الانتاج وبقي
الطلب كما هو عليه فان الاسعار سترتفع ولم
يتوقف لوني هنا بل كان مديحا في منظمه
اوبك مثمنا دورها في تعزيز استقرار اسعار
النفط مشيرا الى ان اوبك تحاول دعم
استقرار الاسعار حتى تتمكن شركات النفط في
العالم من الاستثمار في امدادات النفط
المستقبليه وتامينها لنستمع الى هذه
الجزئيه من الحوار مع الرئيس التنفيذي
لبيبي
[موسيقى]
وبهذا مشاهدينا ناتي الى ختام هذه الحلقه
من مستقبل الطاقه للمزيد تابعونا على
تويتر تحت وسم هاشتاج مستقبل الطاقه
يمكنكم ايضا الاستماع الى حلقاتنا على
العربيه بودكاست اما لمشاهده حلقات
البرنامج كامله زوروا موقعنا على الانترنت
العربيه دوت نت سلاش بروجرامس
شكرا لحسن متابعتكم مشاهدينا ونعود
والقاكم في نفس الموعد الاسبوع المقبل الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات